[Music]
in triggered news submitted by get off
your phones never on the phone I see you
guys because you're watching us probably
hang up my phone then stay on your
phones
a CNN host I saw this I never watch Cena
know if you saw this but it was kind of
interesting all of them is fake news
angry hears that like Trump okay
oh yeah cuz he always called CNN fake
news I think all news is fake news
including ours how about that now I'm
being equally fair unbiased I could just
talk for so long emoji I said what
happened with the CNN host he died oh
I'm a big car accident and Godzilla yeah
whatever a CNN host was caught on camera
angrily clashing with a man who called
him Fredo Fredo Fredo being the
character from Godfather which is also
being somewhat racial slur for Italian
people that's what he's claiming I think
it's somewhat true it's like short for
alfredo but it's a name I've never seen
this movie I don't know but it's from
the Godfather and number one or two I
don't know brain oh I forgot wait was he
the boss of the other guy no so he was
called the oldest part of the good good
the protagonist family so they're saying
that he's like one of the brothers and
like apparently he brought Amy key in
the back stabbing the main brother the
Mafia family thing I don't know
I don't you think you kind of watch it
we watch the beginning of it is a
Latinos brother in the movie is slow
though Michael's brother is a Michael
Corleone it starts slow but it gets
[ __ ] good cuz I know what you're
talking about yeah I fell asleep four
times on that [ __ ]
it feels so slow to watch now a lot of
those old movies like oh god with the
Goldfarb old father but the buildup is
good though yep cuz it opens on the
Godfather and the guy pretty much Begley
held me there but the my daughter and
you're like oh [ __ ] this guy's a
gangster no sure way is his daughter's
wedding and you just keep started
zooming out of the world
know about the Godfather because of like
pop culture references that's it
I've never seen the movie but anyway so
we're talking about pretty good mo here
he is a CNN anchor he's also a kid
brother of New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo so he was in New York this is all
he looks like by the way he was chillin
with his wife and his kid he looks like
a better-looking Steve Buscemi
what's so lack of all and this is a if
you've ever seen Wolf Blitzer on
celebrity jeopardy you know I'm talking
about these people act like they're
smart they're they put all the sources
oh I know everything but if you [ __ ]
take this [ __ ] up they'll know nothing
yeah not they're not as smart as they
tried it really good at reading a
teleprompter
why they're actors so this is the
character we're talking about Frodo here
that's all the way so someone what he
fighter I think okay so he approached he
was approached by this dude that called
him Fredo I would have been like yeah
and then Chris just exploded on him so
this is what happened
well did he do an italian-style please
tell me he did
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that guy became like a nine-year-old
little boy
both the glasses okay right no he's been
calm all the good yeah he sounds like
he's like backing up like scared I think
he sounds like Steve Wynn I don't think
that guy's dominating them no the guys
getting so emotional
yeah and the guys kind of trolling oh
yeah exactly
he's controlling you think keeps
trolling him or he really thought I
think he's deadly I was wrong so what
did this angry that guy's getting the
mornings like I thought it was your
names are those it's not afraid of oh
[ __ ] I'm mad dude drawling cuz I feel
like he was playing that role to get him
more pissed yeah exactly yeah yeah but
these people Chris Cuomo especially acts
like he's like the arbiter of what's
ethical on on TV talk to talk like
whether it's Trump or whoever it is it's
like he shouldn't like like waving his
finger at all these people and it's like
this happens you do the same thing man
you lose your temper temperature lose
your shirt and go down in degrees no you
different people do like they try to act
like they're perfect in like I wear a
suit and I told her I couldn't light and
these guys are bad and on ethic once
acknowledge their person - oh really
ironic thing about this whole story that
I find is super hilarious is the fact
that from what I understand about Fredo
like the character he ended up acting
exactly like that character oh [ __ ] I
ain't called Fredo they like be really
struck a nerve here was funny is when he
said hey he said it was like the n-word
yeah like if you said the f-word it
wouldn't mean the first two words yeah
the f-word there's two F words that are
what you would think of [ __ ] and you
would think of [ __ ] before he even
thought you would nobody would be like
at the f-word is free most people don't
even know that there's something that's
going on here where he's sick of being
called Fredo and he was like the alright
calls me Fredo and I'm like so he's
reading blogs
he's like a reading for these negative
comments and getting butthurt or
something right yeah but like is that
something like people have been roasting
him and trolling him and call him Fredo
well that's what he said were Jan or
something it is that's what he is a kid
brother of the governor so it's like
he's already placed in that like he's
the lamer brother
so it's Freddy the brother that's in the
shadows who's also like kind of like a
backstabbing weirdo and oh so yeah
that's kind of funny
he ended up apologizing obviously and
saying like oh you know I lost my temper
and all this stuff like I should act
better if they both look like children
[Music]
but the other conversation around this
issue here like this whole incident is
how because he works for CNN he kind of
gets like a pass from wait so he doesn't
get is he doesn't lose his job or
anything like that no yeah like nothing
there's no repercussions you're saying
it yours for like Fox or something
people will probably be on him exactly
that's the car
[Applause]
I mean that's what they're saying around
all this it's like oh because he's on
the left like he's kind of getting away
with it and also CNN is saying like you
know he was being discriminated against
and attacked and so he defended himself
we're gonna stand you discriminated
against those people at Fox if there's
people that Fox have done some [ __ ]
they've done some bad things if this was
1883
maybe Italians could be like as people
of color yeah but I don't know if today
they qualify as a minority group there
were a lot of Italians too coming out
saying like hold on not even that's
what's the real Italian like bad word is
it Guinea or
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah very loose never
heard of these but they were the racist
terms back then because what Italians
Irish and Jewish weren't considered
white no he just tried to make it a
bigger deal and hiding this to like
compare it to the n-word I don't think
there's a lot of things that's compared
to that no like yeah he's trying to
justify his anger and like a manly
assertive assertiveness like what's
wrong in a general sense not just for me
personally of course not just for me I'm
fighting for what's wrong I'm fighting
for my Italian people you should be
ashamed if you're always been when
people stand up and act like that like
it was the same thing with a dude Alec
Baldwin like people that are on the left
that act like they're they're like how
dare bah and it's like [ __ ] look
at look in your own house yeah open your
own closet the stupid [ __ ] you'd be
doing that's why you don't affiliate
yourself with no one I don't stand for
nothing if you don't stand for you could
be as US biggest scoundrel as you want
don't [ __ ] matter man
don't stand for [ __ ] people are gonna
expect so much out of you yeah good for
you job yeah so Fox Muse shot a host
Sean Hannity
he backed him up and backed up to CNN
guy yeah he backed up Chris he said this
see now that's a right and a left
working together corrupt media there you
go so he wrote this tweet which says I
think good for Chris Cuomo he's out with
his a nine year old daughter and his
wife and this guy's being a jackass in
front of us
family in my opinion Chris Cuomo has
zero to apologize for he deserves the he
deserves the apology in my honest that's
because that's because Sean Hannity
knows what it's like to be out see
that's not a right and laughing yeah
that is a journal in your like celebrity
thing it's like good for you these
[ __ ] trolls man but Chris was Fredo
also the truth hurts totally lost it low
ratings do you think he knows he's that
[ __ ] funny dude it's kind of doing
what in a weird way he's doing would you
said if you don't stand for nothing you
say like yeah I grabbed her by the [ __ ]
what what the [ __ ] do you what are you
gonna do and then you can release a
that's true cuz people are expecting the
president to deny it
like Bill Clinton like I didn't have sex
with that woman but Trump's like know
Bill Clinton [ __ ] up oh he should have
said yeah I [ __ ] her I did and I came
all over that dress I did come on that
lady the trumpet was the one that
started this conversation around how
like because Chris is left so this is
what he said when a conservative does it
even a fraction of what Chris Cuomo did
with his lunatic ranting raving and
cursing they get destroyed by the fake
news but when a liberal Democrat like
Chris Cuomo does it Republicans
immediately come to his defense we never
learned we never learned
yeah it's not true because during Bush's
campaign I felt like everything was okay
for the right and then everything was
shut down for the left so he's even
throwing his own people under the bus
drop
well yes what it sounds like I mean he's
been a David Democrat for most of his
life it's just recently
so how about one tweet he's going both
of them under the bus I mean he throws
himself under the bus to you Joe yeah
don't stab for nothing guys
[Music]
[Music]